24/7.
THIS PRESIDENT PROMISED YOU MORE
JOBS.
IN 501 DAY HES IS DELIVERIY.
JOINING US THE FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA.
JOE, 18 MONTHS LATER, I HAVE A
PROBLEM, WE HAD A GOOD RESULT IN
THE CASE OF McCABE WHERE THERE
WAS A CRIMINAL RER FALNOW.
-- REFERRAL.
NOW ROB ROSENSTEIN AND THE DOJ
HAVE HAD THIS REPORT FOR 2
WEEKS.
THE SAME GUY THAT OBSTRUCTED
CONGRESS AND WON'T HAND OVER THE
DOCUMENTS THEY SUBPOENAED, WHY
DO I NOT TRUST HIM THAT THEY
WANT REDACTIONS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES?
>> THE REASON IS SIMPLE, SEAN.
ROB ROSENSTEIN IS A CAREERIST.
HE BELIEVES IN THE INSTITUTION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI TO THE EXCLUSION OF ANY
ACCUSATIONS OF FAULT.
THE IG REPORT IS BEING SCRUBBED
BY ROSENSTEIN TO REMOVE AS MUCH
EMBARRASSING INFORMATION ABOUT
THE BUREAU AS POSSIBLE.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S GOING TO BE
DELAY THE RELEASE OF THE REPORT
AND PERHAPS PUT IT OUT DURING
THE SINGAPORE SUMMIT.
THIS CONDUCT BY ROSENSTEIN AND
THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DELAY IS REPREHENSIBLE.
BUT IT'S A PATTERN.
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS THEY
WANT TO HURT THE PRESIDENT.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WANTS TO HURT THE PRESIDENT AND
PREVENT THE RELEASE OF TRUTHFUL
INFORMATION TO DENY
TRANSPARENCIES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHAT HAPPENED DURING THE
CAMPAIGN AND WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
SERVER INVESTIGATION IS A
NATIONAL DISGRACE.
ROSENSTEIN SHOULD BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF RELEASING THAT
INFORMATION.
INSTEAD HE IS TRYING TO HIDE
SUBSTANTIAL PORTIONS OF IT.
>> Sean: IT WON'T BE MICHAEL
HOROWITZ THAT DECIDES THE
RELEASE DATE.
IF IT'S RELEASED NOW THROUGH
NEXT WEEK WITH THIS HISTORIC
SINGAPORE SUMMIT WITH KIM
JONG-UN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP, DO
YOU AGREE THEY ARE BURYING IT
DURING ONE OF THE MOST HISTORIC
SUMMITS IN HISTORY?
>> WELL, THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT'S THEIR INTENT.
OTHERWISE THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN
RELEASE AID LONG TIME AGO.
THE REASON IT'S DELAYED IS TO
ALLOW THE LEAKS WHEN YOU SAW
TODAY, THE PARTIAL LEAK OF THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE COMEY
INSUBORDINATION.
HE WAS MORE THAN THAT.
HE SUBVERTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
LORETTA LYNCH WAS COMPROMISED.
THERE SAT SALLY YATES WHO COULD
HAVE DESCRIBED WHAT HAPPENED AND
DECIDED THIS CASE ON BEHALF OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW IS THEY
ARE DELAYING TO PREVENT TIMELY
DISCLOSURE.
>> Sean: YOU ARE CONVINCED THEY
WILL TRY TO BURY THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: WHO WOULD MAKE THAT
DECISION?
>> IT'S ROB ROSENSTEIN.
THE REPORT EVEN THOUGH IT'S
GOING TO CONGRESS IS CONTROLLED
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO MAKE
CHANGES FOR NATIONAL SECURITY OR
OTHER REASONS.
>> Sean: 2 WEEKS WORTH OF
REDACTIONS.
>> THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
>> Sean: AND REMEMBER THE FBI
DIRECTOR ASSIGNED ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE TO RESPOND MORE QUICKLY.
LET'S GO TO WHAT HAS COME OUT TO
THE INSUBORDINATION ISSUE.
WE KNOW THE FACTS IN THIS CASE.
IT'S INDISPUTABLE AT THIS POINT.
HILLARY CLINTON VIOLATED THE
ESPIONAGE ACT AND PUT TOP SECRET
INFORMATION ON A PRIVATE SERVER.
THAT'S ILLEGAL AND LIED ABOUT
IT.
AND AS I SAID, NOW THAT ROBERT
MUELLER WANTS EVERYBODY'S PHONES
IN CASE THEY USE ONE OF THESE
APPLICATIONS, HE WANTS ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION I WONDER IF
EVERYBODY DOES WHAT HILLARY
CLINTON DID.
LET'S THE APP AND ACID WATCH THE
PHONE AND TAKE THE SIMCARDS OUT
HOW WOULD THAT WORK OUT FOR
ROBERT MUELLER?
>> THEY WOULD OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
THAT WASN'T THE WAY HILLARY
CLINTON WAS TREATED.
JAMES COMEY CONDUCTED A
FRAUDULENT INVESTIGATION.
NO SUSPECTS.
-- SUBPOENAS.
MASSIVE IMMUNITY.
YOU HAVE A DOUBLE STANDARD.
IT'S VISIBLE FROM THE WAY
MUELLER IS CONDUCTING HIS
INVESTIGATION.
THE ULTIMATE PRESSURE OPPOSED TO
THE NO PRESSURE IN THE HILLARY
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: AND THE LARGER ROLE?
WE ONLY HAVE A SAMPLING OF TEXT
MESSAGES OF PETER STRZOK.
THE HATRED THEY HAD FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
WE BROKE A STORY THAT SAID IT
WAS RUN OUT OF THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY WERE WRITING THE
EXONERATION IN MAY AND THIS WAS
JULY.
HE LIEED TO THE FBI AND WAS
INVOLVED IN THE INVESTIGATION OF
TRUMP AND ROBERT MUELLER
APPOINTED THIS GUY.
WHEN ARE THE CHARGES AGAINST HIM
COMING?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
DOUBT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT WILL DEAL WITH ALL OF
THAT.
PETER STRZOK IS A SERIOUS
PERSON.
HE WOULD BE SOMEONE BECAUSE OF
THE KNOWLEDGE HE HAS OF COMEY,
HE MAY BE IMMUNIZED.
THERE WILL BE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
FROM THE INVESTIGATION INVOLVING
THE WAY THE FBI COVERED UP THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION LED BY THE
SENIOR DIRTY COP JAMES COMEY
THROUGH THE CASE.
IT'S THE MOST EMBARRASSING
SITUATION IN THE FBI.
>> Sean: THERE ARE FBI AGENTS
THAT WANT TO TELL THE STORY OF